you're watching al jazeera we're
bringing you live pictures from the
senate floor in washington dc on capitol
hill where
the senate minority leader mitch
mcconnell has been talking initially
about the security preparations that
were in place at the capitol on
january the 6th when the riots there
took place he then went on to start
talking about
the filibuster mechanism which is a
political mechanism
by which senators are able to
essentially talk out
any part of legislation which is placed
before them i believe it requires a
minimum
of 60 votes to pass but i want to get
more details on this
uh from heidi jo castro who's been
listening to this heidi just give bring
us up to date if you can
on the importance of the filibuster
mechanism in this and
why it matters so much at this time
well rob as you know right now there is
a
democratic majority in the senate but by
the thinnest of margins
it's 50 50 in fact the number of
senators of both parties but we have
that key
uh tie-breaking vote of vice president
kamala harris
and so most legislation going forward
needs to be bipartisan because as you
mentioned there's that filibuster rule
that's been in place that would require
more than just the simple majority
now what some have called the nuclear
option is for
uh the the leader uh chuck schumer
to remove that rule which would give
democrats the ability to essentially
force through
their agenda on that slimmest of margins
if every single democrat
plus the vice president votes for a
certain
piece of legislation that is something
that joe biden
appears to be adverse to he of course
has just
been sworn into office and he campaigned
on unity
he is telling he's told voters voters
that he would be able
to bring together both parties and
finally see some
bipartisan action here in capitol hill
that's been missing
throughout uh all of trump's years and
much of obama's
as well so there's so much discussion
this this rule this procedure to get rid
of the filibuster
if that were to take place would be
significant
in that it would give democrats the
ability
again to pass through their legislation
given the current makeup
of congress without having to convince
any republicans to join them heidi i do
want to ask you
um something that is uh probably more
important the fact that
just prior to mitch mcconnell speaking
we heard chuck schumer just briefly
talking about the
fact that nancy pelosi is going to bring
in
the impeachment action on monday
now this of course is the impeachment
against president that's right donald
trump
and that's the the closest that we've
gotten from anyone as far as the next
step
timeline because of course the thing
we're waiting on now is for nancy pelosi
speaker of the house
to transmit that article of impeachment
she would not say yesterday when
that would happen and now as you as you
mentioned
schumer the senate majority leader has
just said that that
that transmission will occur monday so
what happens after that
well we would expect that the senate has
until the following day that's
tuesday to bring go back into session
and start discussing
the uh the shape that this impeachment
trial
will take that is squarely within
the power of chuck schumer
the senate majority leader now of the
democrats to craft how he wants this
trial to happen we heard from
from the now minority leader mitch
mcconnell
giving out his proposal for how he would
like
trump's impeachment trial he doesn't
want this trial to begin until
mid-february
in order to give the former president
attorneys
time to come up with a defense
we're not exactly sure how chuck schumer
or the remaining democrats
feel about that though it may actually
play to the democrats favor too
given that they want the senate to be
able to finish this confirmation
process for joe biden's cabinet
so still unclear exactly what how this
this trial will take place but the the
most solid piece of
information we've got to hang our hats
on at this point is that on monday
the article of impeachment which charges
uh former president trump with inciting
insurrection uh will be marched across
the capitol rotunda and delivered to the
senate which is the first step
in getting and setting up for that trial
that at this point is proposed to begin
in mid-february
heidi thanks very much indeed that's
heidi jo castro bringing us up to date
from the capitol